[MUSIC PLAYING]
NICK ORLOVE: First things
first, let's make sure
that you're in the right room.
A show of hands, who
cares about cloud costs,
controlling your cloud
costs, not overspending?
Most of you, so you
found the right room.
For those of you who
did not raise your hands
and therefore cost is no object,
throw as much money as you can,
make sure you find
me after the session
and I'll introduce you
to some sales reps who
would love to meet you guys.
All jokes aside, my
name is Nick Orlove.
I'm a customer engineer
with Google Cloud.
In a few minutes, I'm going to
be joined with Elad Amit, who
is the director of product
development at Perimeter X,
and we have a really
exciting talk for you today.
So what we'll be going
through is essentially
the why and more importantly
the how of cloud management--
cloud cost management.
We'll do a deep dive into
how to tie your KPIs--
your business KPIs
to those costs,
things like how
much does it cost
to bring on a new customer.
How much does it
cost to sell a widget
or to get an extra pair of
eyeballs looking at your ad
or to click on a
link, et cetera?
We'll go through some real world
problems, some real scenarios
on how to accomplish that.
And we'll wrap it up with
some best practices and Q&A.
Speaking of Q&A, one
of the exciting things
that we have for
this next session
is something called
Dory, so everyone
when we go to the Q&A segment
can ask questions online.
This is open right now.
So essentially if you just
open up your next app,
go to the session, the
CST302, submit Dory questions
through the plus sign, and
then you can thumbs up,
thumbs Dory questions.
At the end of this
session, we'll
have about 10 minutes
or so for Q&A,
and we'll be alternating
between the Dory as well
as the in-person mics.
So definitely use that
if it's convenient.
So why analyze your cloud costs?
I think the first
reason is going
to be pretty self-explanatory.
Costs are directly tied to
revenue of your business.
It's a bit of a
delicate equation here.
And the most important part
is costs do sometimes go up.
But if costs go
up, you also have
to make sure that income is
going up on par or preferably
at a faster pace than costs.
This is going to be critical
to your overall business,
but it's also crucial
for each business
unit and each team that
contributes to these costs.
So providing these
business metrics,
not only to CFOs,
CIOs, et cetera,
but also to those teams who
are engineering and building
these solutions is
pretty powerful.
Second is usage is directly tied
to costs in the cloud world.
With on-prem environments,
truthfully, it
was a little bit
easier to manage
costs, because you
bought one server,
and that server essentially
cost roughly the same
whether you were
at 0% utilization
or 100% utilization.
And so when you wanted
your app to scale,
you were really bound by that
single server or x number
of servers.
And if you had wished it could
multiply into multiple servers,
it just didn't have
that capability.
With cloud, things
operate differently,
differently in a good way.
By things like auto scaling, by
being able to click and deploy
new server instances,
you can essentially
grow your application from
one server to 10 to 100
to 1,000 in seconds and minutes.
But there is a
slight caveat there
in that usage is tied to
cost and that as you use more
resources, your costs increase.
So much more important
in this environment
to actually keep
an eye on how much
your resources are
costing you and be
able to kind of turn
that dial and adjust
as you need the amount of
resources that you have
and the amount of costs that are
contributing to your business.
Third thing is being in control.
So by moderating your
costs, you are the point
of control for your business.
You can determine
how much you're
spending on GCE, for
instance, and how that's
contributing to your business.
You can keep track of what one
business unit is contributing
to a business versus
another business unit,
one team versus
another team, one
individual versus another
individual, et cetera.
Potentially, who's running
all those select stars
in your business.
And fourth thing is
being intelligent.
So the saying goes that data
is the new oil, the new gold,
et cetera.
And that's very true.
The more data you
gather, the more
that you can actually
do with that data.
So by actually collecting
that data, by gathering it,
you can do more advanced things,
like building dashboards that
compare your costs to your KPIs,
which we'll be going through
during this session.
But you can also do
more advanced things
like building ML models to
predict what your costs might
be in the future, or of building
ML models to potentially
predict where you need to
focus your efforts on product
XYZ or widget ABC, et cetera.
And most importantly, you
will inevitably save money.
So by actually
monitoring your costs,
you will be able to
keep track of your costs
and be able to tweak those
spending habits over time.
So I don't know if you've
done this yourself,
but a couple of years back
I started more thoroughly
analyzing my personal finances
and was totally shocked
to find out how much the
occasional $5 cup of coffee
or the occasional dinner out
with friends et cetera actually
ended up costing me at
the end of the month.
And so by keeping
an eye on that,
tracking that, and actually
tailoring my spending habits,
I ended up saving roughly about
10% per month in, once again,
my personal friends finances.
So by actually
just keeping an eye
and monitoring your spend
costs, you will inevitably
end up saving money.
So let's take an example.
Let's say that I just open
up a new, exciting bike share
company called GBike & Co.
As you can see, I'm renting
out these amazing Google
bikes across the streets
of San Francisco.
Business is booming.
Ridership has gone up.
I have more people becoming
members, et cetera.
But what I really want to
do is start identifying
how much my business
is costing me
and actually convert something
like the number of bikes that
are being ridden
across the street
to an intelligent dashboard
to show my bike trips
are increasing while my
costs are decreasing,
stuff like that, actually
providing more data
to these numbers or
these assumptions.
And that's what we're going
to do during this session.
So first I want to talk
about kind of the cost
management 101,
or what you can do
right out of the
gate immediately
through the Google
Cloud Console.
First being built-in reports--
So the Cloud Console
has some fantastic
built in reports that allow you
to actually tailor and drill
down into specific projects,
into specific environments
to see what those costs
are and maybe identify
potential red flags, identify
trends over time, et cetera.
And by way, all of
these, we'll kind of
go through some quick
demos in a couple minutes.
Second being resource
hierarchy-- so
rather than bundling
everything, all your GCP
resources, into one,
quote, unquote, "bucket"
or one project, being able
to intelligently separate
one project from another.
Maybe you have one
business unit that's
doing one thing versus
another business unit,
applying tags, using
organizations, projects,
folders, et cetera.
For an example, my bike
business, like I said,
has been booming, but I'm
interested in growing up
a separate business unit.
I'm going to be expanding
into electric scooters.
For everyone in San
Francisco, there's
one thing that we need more of,
and that is electric scooters.
So I'm going to be
building this out,
and I would essentially put
that under a separate project
so that I can more accurately
compare business units
between those two projects.
Third being budgets and alerts--
so in the Cloud Console,
you can set specific budgets
and alert on those budgets
at a very granular level
so that if a project goes
over a certain threshold,
or a billing account goes
you don't have to
be left in the dark
and find out with that angry
call at the month's end
to find out why your
project cost so much money.
You can get that
alert way before
and start to dial
down those knobs
and actually control your costs.
By the way, these
aren't the only things
for the cost management 101.
Besides these kind
of out of the box,
you have a billing API to do
some more advanced things.
You can set quotas
for your resources.
We have a ML
capability for actually
recommending the
specific machine
types in GCE, stuff like that.
So I definitely recommend
kind of identifying
all the different areas
that you could go into this.
But what we're really
interested in this session
is kind of more the advanced
stuff beyond the 101.
And so what I'm
going to be doing
is more pulling out a billing
export from my Cloud Console,
importing that into
BigQuery, and then doing
some analytics across it
to identify potentially
what my spend is, trends
over time, et cetera.
And BigQuery being Google's
fully managed data warehouse
allows me to do things
like break down data silos,
do some complex join, some
creative SQL, et cetera,
so that I can actually bring
in some of my business data,
some of my KPIs, pull that
into the same project, or even
a different project
within BigQuery,
join across that,
and then of output
some interesting reports through
something like Data Studio--
or really pick your BI
provider of choice--
and provide these dashboards
to management, to leadership,
or even to teams and
engineers to kind of get
a better grasp of their spend.
So I'm going to,
just real quick, go
through some of the 101 stuff.
So on my screen, you can see
I have the billing reports up.
I'm looking at a range
from the 25th to the 9th.
By the way, all
these are just kind
of dummy numbers and stuff.
This is an actual
project, but the numbers
that I'm going to be going
through for this demo
are purely fictitious.
So over here in the
Projects, I can actually
expand this to include
multiple projects.
So you can see this
blue line being
my production project,
the NEXT demo,
my orange line
being the Test Dev.
I can also, instead of
grouping it by project,
I can group it by product.
So you can see that the
majority of my costs
is going to Spanner, and
then I have some GCE.
I can further break
it down by SKU.
So I can find out exactly
what my spends are over time,
and I can even do some
advanced drill down
to kind of get a clearer picture
of what the spend looks like.
And in the previous
image you can actually
see the trend line over time.
Granted, this might not
be the most accurate.
It kind of depends on how much
data that's feeding into it
to make these projections.
And because this project was
started relatively recently,
not the most accurate
thing in the world.
Besides that, I have
Budgets and Alerts.
So in here you see that I
have two separate alerts that
are set, one for a
$1,000 NEXT demo.
So at a specific
project level, anything
that exceeds a 50%,
90%, and 100% threshold,
send me alerts on.
I also have one for
the billing account,
so all the different projects
within that billing account,
for a $5,000 limit.
To create a budget, I can
simply go to Test Dev.
I'm going to pick
my Test Dev project.
I'm going to set it to be $100.
Maybe $50 is a little bit
too low to receive alerts on,
so I'll change it to $80.
And I'll click Save.
And there you go.
Now all of a sudden, I have a
new budget that's been created,
and that's going to alert me
if my Test Dev team decides
to go crazy and
start spinning up
a whole bunch of environments.
Next is the Billing
Export, so I'll go here.
There's two different ways
to export your billing data.
First is through BigQuery.
This would be my
preferred option.
It means that you can do
more with that data that's
been exported.
You can also export
your data as a CSV.
To export the data in BigQuery,
it is an automatic every day
sync between your budget
data and BigQuery.
So what I do is simply
hit this Edit Settings,
pick the project that I want
to export my billing data into,
the BigQuery data set
that I want to export--
San Francisco Bike Company.
I'll click Save.
And there we go.
Now it's enabled,
and every day it's
going to start syncing my
billing data into BigQuery
so I can do more
advanced stuff with that.
So let's go to BigQuery and
see what that looks like.
It roughly takes
a handful of hours
to get that first billing
export into BigQuery,
so what I've done is I
actually have a billing export
already in BigQuery itself.
And if you look at
this schema, you
can see that it's capturing
some pretty decent information.
So I have billing account IDs.
You can see what service or
SKU I'm spending my money
on, projects, labels,
the specific location--
whether you're running your GCE
instance in Asia or the Us--
total cost, usage, credits,
all that kind of stuff.
So some really good data.
The challenge is that I want
to make this more insightful
and actually compare
it to my business KPIs.
And so for my business data
set, or business table,
I have this SF Bike Trips
table in my data set.
So by the way, this
SF Bike Trips table
is just essentially a
copy of the public data
set for the San Francisco Bike.
So by all means, feel free
to explore this yourself
and have at it.
For this data, essentially
what I'm capturing
is information on
every single trip
that my customers are taking.
So I have the total
duration of the trips,
when the trip started
and stopped and where.
I have information on whether
that customer was a subscriber,
i.e.
like a monthly paid
membership, or just someone
who walked off the street and
took a ride on my bicycle.
And so what I'll do essentially
is join these two tables
with a simple SQL query.
I think everyone
can still see that.
And so essentially
what I'll do is a join
between these two tables.
So I have this SF Bike
Trips table first off,
and what I'm pulling
out of this table
is the relevant
information for me.
So I have the number
of trips, where
I'm counting the total number of
trips per day, total duration,
the date itself.
I'm counting
whether the customer
was a subscriber or just
an off the street customer.
And then I'm joining that
to my billing export.
And from my billing export,
all I'm doing is pulling out
the particular day and
the total cost per day.
So you can see that this
is relatively simple,
but you can take this to the
next level of potentially which
areas are the most profitable
for me with this bike data.
That might tell
me maybe I should
start placing more bikes
in a particular area
or remove bikes
from other areas.
It might break in to
things like maintenance.
And I could do joins
across multiple tables
and identify, OK, I have
a team of five people who
do maintenance on these bikes.
Where do I need to send
them to be a little bit more
strategic with this?
And so I'll go ahead
and click Run Query.
And you can see--
once it finishes-- you can see
that the query has broken out
the total number of trips--
I'll just hide this--
total number of trips and
compared it to the cost.
So on average I have somewhere
between 2,000 and 4,000 trips
per day.
My subscriber numbers
seem to be pretty healthy.
My total cost per day-- once
again, totally fictitious-- is,
I don't know, somewhere
between $20 and $30 per day.
So it looks pretty good.
However, the challenge is that
to my just normal human eyes,
I can't really spot trends in
this data, so what I would do
is actually open this
up in Data Studio.
So there's this fantastic
Explore in Data Studio button
that's going to open up a
new Data Studio project.
But let me just show you the
one that I've already created.
This took about five minutes,
so it's incredibly easy.
And what I have is a couple
of different data points,
so first, let's look at this
cost versus KPI dashboard
up here.
The blue line you can see are
the total number of trips.
And so there seems to be a
pretty common trend here where
maybe bikes get ridden
more during the work days
and then less
during the weekends.
People are riding their
own bikes, stuff like that,
hanging out with their kids,
et cetera, on the weekends.
Makes sense.
And you can see that the red
bars are my total cost per day.
Now, what I didn't
tell you earlier
is that I've actually started
a new initiative to find out
if I can adopt more bike
riders with let's just call it
a mobile app.
And so I started
spending more money
on this mobile application
somewhere around mid-February.
And you can see that my costs
have increased, however,
the blue line, the
total number of trips,
hasn't really increased.
In fact, there's some
interesting dips.
I mean, potentially,
maybe it was
rain or something like that.
But right out of the
gate, you can kind of
see that maybe this business
initiative isn't really
as successful as I
first planned it to be.
And so I can look
at these numbers
down here below, which kind
of summarize the total numbers
across the month.
And this actually
proves my point in
that GCB costs per
month have risen
by 55%, kind of a warning sign
unless the bike trips have also
increased.
But they're actually down by
6.2%, so a little concerning.
The subscribers are also
down, and my non-subscribers
have only increased by 1%
So right off the bat, I can
take this data to my business,
to CFO or CTO et
cetera, and kind of
show him that maybe this trend,
or this business initiative,
really isn't panning
out as much as possible.
So this is more of a kind
of theoretical exercise,
more of like the book smarts.
I'd like to invite
Elad Amit onstage
to talk through more of the
street smarts of actually
putting this into practice
and all the business value
you are able to contribute
back to PerimeterX.
ELAD AMIT: Thank you very much.
Thanks for that
great intro, Nick.
Like you said, my
name is Elad Amit.
I'm the director of platform
development over at PerimeterX,
where my team is primarily in
charge of scaling our product.
And one of the things that
entails is cost management.
Just for a context,
what we actually do
is something called
bot mitigation.
That is, we ingest a
boatload of traffic.
We analyze it, and
we use it to block
all sorts of malicious traffic,
stuff like account abuse,
account takeover,
credit card theft,
all sorts of nasty
little things.
And the problem is that
a boatload of traffic
costs a boatload of money, so
naturally we try and give it
the attention it deserves.
Now, I know you were
promised a demo,
but instead, what I'm going
to do is tell you a story,
switch to a demo.
It's really a demo.
Now, like every good
story, we have characters,
and our specific story
starts with our CFO, who
was actually quite angry with us
at the time, and rightfully so.
I mean, all he
wanted to know was
what our cloud bills
are going to be
like at the end of the month.
And though that may sound
like a trivial question,
this was like two years ago.
And two years ago,
what we mostly had
was old flat file export
that looked kind of like this
with very, very
little dimensions
that we could kind of figure
out what we were doing.
And though, as Nick showed
you a second ago, these days
you already have these
nifty little projections
that you can understand
what's going on,
at the time they didn't exist.
For us, the real turning point
was when we started using DoiT
and their tool called
reOptimize to kind of start
figuring out a little bit better
where we're going to be at.
This is specifically reOptimize
with some projections
that you can see here.
At that point, our CFO was
quite happy, but as we grew
and as we matured,
people started asking
some really weird questions.
I mean, up till
then, people asked,
how much is stuff going to cost?
And at that point
in time, people
started asking, how much
is my stuff going to cost?
This totally blew our minds.
So as we go into
the billing export
that Nick showed you
a second ago, what
you can see, at the default
that you're getting,
is mostly semantics based on
what Google is selling you.
I'm not saying that
as a negative thing,
because that's actually
what you're paying for.
But if you can see here,
what you're mostly seeing
is stuff like custom instance,
yadda, yadda, yadda, containers
this, active storage that.
And making the leap
from that to whatever it
is that you're building
is somewhere between
hard and impossible.
Now thankfully enough,
at that point--
that this was like a
year and a half ago--
the billing export started
getting the user defined labels
pushed into them, and
surprisingly enough they
were always there.
When we were using them
mostly for operational
stuff to kind of
break down what we
were using within production.
And not surprisingly
enough, we wanted
to use the same breakdown
to kind of figure
out where our costs were going.
And to kind of simplify
our lives a little bit,
we chose to expose this
additional data using a view,
mostly because we wanted to
take away the complexity--
and you'll see the complexity a
little further down the line--
of how to figure out which
specific dimensions are really
interesting and which are not.
Now specifically
within this view,
you're going to want to notice
two things, the first of which
is that we're exporting a
column called Partition Time.
This basically allows the
BigQuery query, or Data Studio
querying BigQuery, to
prune the partitions
and make your queries
a little bit cheaper.
For us the billing data set is
already around two terabytes,
so it adds up, and
it makes sense.
And the second thing you're
going to want to notice
is that we're
trying to take away
the complexity of
un-nesting repeated fields.
If you're going
to be using this,
I highly recommend you
read up on un-nested fields
because you can make really,
really bad mistakes with them.
So what we have
here specifically
is a summary of the amount of
credits and the specific label
that we want to use.
And if we go back to
our Data Studio reports,
then we can see that once
we break down our cost based
on this new billing
component that we've added,
then the semantics
you change completely
from what Google is selling to
what we are actually building.
Here we can see how much the
specific front end component
is costing us, how much
this specific Elasticsearch
cluster is costing us.
And this isn't just
the cores or the RAM
or any specific piece,
it's everything.
The other nifty little thing
that you get when you add this
is that you can now not
only see the overall spend,
or just by SKU or by component.
Once you break down a specific
component by the SKUs,
then you can figure out where
to focus your development
efforts on optimization,
which is with this whole talk
is about.
So if you take, for example,
that online component, then
we can see that it is mostly
a CPU intensive resource.
You can see this is Custom
Instance Core in America--
it's out of Virginia if
I remember correctly--
and so on and so forth.
And to contrast that, we
have this little thing, which
is mostly a network
intensive resource.
Now another thing to
notice is that, while you
would have probably gotten this
from operational dashboards,
you would have not
gotten the fact
that it is using network, which
is that much more expensive.
For those of you
who have already
been using GCP, or pretty
much any other cloud provider,
you know that not all
networking costs the same.
Some of it costs nothing.
This specific thing costs
a lot, so naturally we
wanted to optimize it.
And if we go further
down the line,
you can also see that throughout
roughly the last five to six
months we've actually
focused our development
efforts on bringing
this network cost down.
And you can see how this nice
little line keeps dropping
and dropping and dropping.
And this kept making our
CFO happier and happier,
which is a lot of my job.
Now somewhere around
this point in time,
you're probably going to try
and squint and figure out
whether all these lines really
mean what I say they meant.
And surprisingly enough, we
had the exact same problem.
It's called cognitive load.
When you look at a graph
with 50 lines trying
to explain what your networking
cost is, another 80 trying
to explain what you're
a CPU costs are like,
you're going to
have a hard time.
And graphs should
be easily read.
At this point, we're going
to jump back to our marvelous
little view, and we're going
to augment it with a case
class, specifically this.
Now, what we were
doing here actually
is we were taking the different
SKUs and trying to group
them into slightly
more coherent groups.
What you'll see here is various
commitments, preemptible cores,
RAM, and all sorts
of networking stuff.
We chose to do this and not
join it with a lookup table
mostly because we have zero
control over the actual SKUs
going into the system, because
they're controlled by Google.
And throughout the
last couple of years,
they have changed
every once in a while.
And what was more
important to us
was to have these groups
as stable as possible.
And now, if we go back here
and we look at the graph
by this nifty little
SKU group, then you
can see that, indeed, I was
not lying through my teeth
and that the main cost--
insanely so-- is this
purple little line
that kept going down and
down and down, again, making
a lot of people happy.
At this point in
time, you're probably
going to try and ask me what
happened during October.
And-- sneak preview--
we did not get a
bunch of coupons
that we entered into the
system dropping our costs.
About two weeks before
this point in time,
we got a lot of people starting
to complain about how they
were losing the bigger picture.
And, you know,
they're quite right.
We went from very
coarse kind of SKU-
and product-based
information all the way down
to the specific
billing component
with nothing in between.
So at that point
in time, naturally,
we started adding more and
more labels onto our resources
to get more information.
Unfortunately, we kind of
missed this little piece
of the documentation,
which basically
says that once you cross the
1,000 unique label value line,
it starts discarding them.
So the end result was a
complete loss of visibility
because it kept the labels
that we weren't actually
interested in.
Now obviously, we fixed it,
but being aggressive people,
we wanted to both
have what we wanted
and still have the
whole thing work.
So we went back
to our view again.
Have I mentioned how
much I like this view?
And here we decided--
let me just make this a
little bit more readable.
Here we decided to join that
building component that we had
with a slightly
smaller data set,
which is just going to be
those enrichments that we
added before.
Since they were
relatively kind of static,
for those of you in the
data warehouse business,
this is kind of like a
star schema but not really.
So here we added stuff
like which product
this specific component
was serving, which service,
the few general details--
whether it was production or
non-production, whether it
was manually scaled or
auto scaled, and a bunch
of other stuff
that I'm not going
to mention here because I don't
want to dive too deep into it.
And then if we again
go back, we can
see that we can now bunch
stuff up into those--
let's call them uber services.
And the difference
here in terms of what
you can do with your
development effort
is that if you usually looked
at just a single component, then
you're going to be doing
some local optimizations.
Here you can look at a
much broader spectrum.
And for example, let's
imagine that this kind of
said for your live front end, or
API, or something of the like.
And here you can start
thinking about slightly
more cross cutting changes,
like using a different protocol
or looking at a different
processing mechanism.
Now at this point in time--
this was, I don't know,
two months ago,
three months ago--
we were ecstatic.
Everything was great.
We were really, really happy.
And then this came along.
Needless to say, a
13% increase in costs
is not a good thing for
anyone and really, really
makes most people
angry, especially when
you keep telling them that
everything is improving.
Or is it?
And the problematic
part is that life
doesn't exist in a vacuum,
especially your costs.
And at that point in time, we
were growing at an insane rate.
And we didn't want to be
the guys who kind of raised
the wrong flag, so we
want it to kind improve
how we were looking
at things and try
to take out that noise
within the signal
that we were looking at.
And the way that
we chose to do this
is start looking at
relative figures instead
of the absolutes.
If you remember, up till
now, we looked at dollars,
and what we decided to look
at was the relative cost
of pushing a million page views
or requests through our system,
and by that kind of try and take
out the traffic fluctuations.
The way that we did that--
back to our marvelous
view-- was, once again,
joining the billing data
with some more business
metrics that were already there
because we run a business,
and we need to know how much
traffic is coming through.
And once we took
this information
and moved back to Data
Studios, you can see--
or what all of you
can do as well--
you can add something called a
calculated field, in this case,
something quite simple.
In case you're not
being able to see this,
this is the final cost divided
by the amount of traffic.
And then when you
look at it, things
start to make
slightly more sense.
Over here you can see that,
as I mentioned before,
everything is fine.
Cost is indeed going up,
but our cost efficiencies
are going down.
Again, this makes most of
the people happy on our end.
Just as an example, if
we take another look
at the service we
looked at before,
this is the same cost efficiency
metric for that service.
And you can see that
indeed it has gone down,
with this day being
a party that we threw
when we went down that low.
To kind of try and
summarize our experiences
from the last couple
of years, I think
what I want to leave you with
is three things, the first
of which is label everything.
And when I say everything,
I mean everything--
at least once, probably
not more than once
because that'll be bad.
But even if you don't
see the value in it now,
you're really going
to want to label it,
because further down the
line when stuff does grow,
you're going to
lose that history.
And that never comes back.
The second is that human
beings are inherently good.
And when you show
them this information,
you're probably
going to be surprised
with the amount of
negative emotions
that they're are
going to throw at you.
What we've found is
that this is mostly
because it's a muscle most
people do not flex that often.
I know a lot of societies
that teach their children how
to manage budgets well
or deal with money,
and the more that
you connect the money
end of things to what
they're actually building
and what they're good
at and practice a lot,
for example, the
building components
or the actual traffic
and the business metrics,
then the more
they're going to be
willing to take
this as something
that they're in charge of.
And the third, SQL
is your friend.
A billing invoice
for us right now
is somewhere between six
and seven million lines
in the billing export.
There's no way that you're going
to be able to understand what's
going on there without
reporting in aggregations,
and that's what SQL is for.
And with that, I turn
the mic back to Nick.
NICK ORLOVE: And can we
switch back to the slides?
So, Elad, you're absolutely
right, making your CFO happy
is critical.
I'm sure everyone has to kind
of figure that out themselves.
Besides your three takeaways, I
also want to add in my three--
or four takeaways actually for
best practices for everyone
who has graciously
attended the session.
First being, on day one, not
day 30, day 90, on day one,
start exporting your
billing data into BigQuery
so that you can
start building costs
analysis dashboards
so you can actually
have that data in
the first place
so that when,
potentially, problems
arise, when you spend increases
beyond what you're expecting,
you have that data so that
you can actually go back in,
do some analysis.
You know exactly
where that data is.
You already have your
dashboards, all that stuff,
instead of, in the
heat of the moment,
trying to collect that data,
figure out where all of it is,
and then run through
all these SQL queries
and stuff like that.
So start capturing
it on day one.
Second this is
structure and organize
your projects, your
organizations, your folders,
your labels, all that
stuff, across all
of your different GCP resources.
So, Elad, you're 100% right,
by just throwing everything
into one single project
or not using labels,
doesn't really give you any
kind of fine-grained control
over what you're spending
on and how those spends
are affecting your
business, et cetera.
So make sure that
you start actually
using resource hierarchies,
labeling assets, putting items
into projects, into
folders, all that stuff.
Third is make sure
that you're configuring
the right kind of policies
for the right kind of people
who have access to control
costs, to set budgets,
to set alerts, all
that kind of stuff.
So rather than just giving
free reign to everyone
to start spending as
much as they want,
maybe you have department
heads or something like that,
or use things like
Google Groups,
or the production
team has more control
over spending habits
than the dev test team,
something like that, so that
spend doesn't go out of control
and you start trying to
scramble and find out
what happened when.
And fourth is building a
culture of showback in your org.
I've talked to a bunch of
different customers about this.
Some customers
call it shameback.
I'll kind of let you guys
decide on which culture
fit is right for your
company, but essentially,
the ability to regularly
review these billing reports
and custom dashboards
with your teams,
with your business
units, et cetera.
And then regularly setting
up budgets and alerts so
that you can closely
monitor your costs,
and you can alert stakeholders
when costs start to increase,
things start to become
concerning, what have you,
so that you can catch
the train way before it
leaves the station.
[MUSIC PLAYING]